shall we in wargames a movie made 30
years ago a young computer hacker from
Seattle comes close to starting a
nuclear war
but these days America is looking to
hire tech-savvy teenagers to work for
the US military
rather than against it and some of these
young cadets at West Point are potential
players a battle I'm fighting is to
educate within the army the the hackers
and what they bring me great strength so
at one of the country's oldest and most
orthodox educational institutions future
officers are learning to think in very
unorthodox ways the approach we're
taking here is more focused on education
and long term underlying principles that
would teach them how to think and how to
solve problems cyber attacks on u.s.
infrastructure swords 1,700 percent
between 2009 and 2011 and in the midst
of that blitz the Pentagon established a
special group to defend America online
general Keith Alexander then head of the
NSA was placed in charge of this new
cyber c'mon initially poaching personnel
from other service branches instead of
developing its own raw recruits but
that's about to change this year for the
first time ever
West Point seniors will be allowed to
join Cyber Command as newly graduated
officers want to see what I can do for
the army as far as applying my expertise
the West Point hacking Club which
competes at national contests against
schools like MIT means these cadets can
compete with the brightest computer
scientists of their generation
I would say I'm more tech savvy than the
average person my age like myself that's
taught in a West Point classroom these
skills may one day be applied on an
active battlefield I see a future where
we'll be cyberspace only operations and
as well as physical world and cyberspace
operations that intersect at various
points in time America's next generation
of army officers will still fight wars
with machine guns but some will also use
Mouse
you